growing up in Kenya I knew I always
wanted to study biochemistry see I had
seen lots of attainder impacts of the
high prevalence of diseases like malaria
and I wanted to make medicines that
would cure the sick so I've really had
got a scholarship to the United States
where I became a cancer researcher and I
loved it for someone who wants to cure
diseases there is no higher calling 10
years later I returned to Kenya to do
just that a freshly minted PhD ready to
take on this horrific yonas which in
Kenya was almost certainly a death
sentence but instead of landing a job
uniform a spherical company or a
hospital I found myself drawn to a
different kind of lab working with a
different kind of patient a patient
whose illness was so serious it impacted
every single person in my country a
patient leader to get healthy fast back
patients was my government
see many of us will agree that lots of
governments are unhealthy today
and Kenya was no exception when I
returned to Kenya in 2014 there was 17%
youth unemployment and there will be the
major business hub was rated a hundred
and seventy-seventh on the quality of
living index it was bad
now an economy is only as healthy as the
entities that make it up
so when government one of its most vital
entities is weak or unhealthy everyone
and everything suffers now sometimes we
might put a bandaid in place to try and
temporarily stop the things maybe some
of you here have participated in a
binded operation to an African country
setting up alternative school building
hospitals digging wells because
governments they are either warrants or
couldn't provide the services to their
citizens now we all know this is a
temporary solution we are just
somethings band-aids can't fix like
providing an environmental businesses
feel secure that they have an equal
opportunity to be able to run and start
their businesses successfully or there
are systems in place that would protect
the private property that they create I
would argue only government is capable
of creating this necessary conditions
for economies to thrive now economists
try when businesses are able to quickly
and easily set up shop business owners
create new sources of income for
themselves new jobs get added into the
economy and then more taxes are paid to
find obvious projects new business is
good for everyone and it's such an
important measure of economic growth
that the World Bank has a ranking called
the Ease of Doing Business ranking which
measures how easy or difficult it is to
set up business in any given country and
as you can imagine studying or running a
business in a country with an alien
government almost impossible the
president of Kenya knew this which is
why in 2014 he came to our lab and asked
us to partner with him to be able to
help Kenya to jumpstart business growth
he set an ambitious goal he wanted to be
who
at Kenya to be ranked top 50 in this
world bank ranking in 2014 when he came
Kenya was run 236 out of 189 countries
we had our work cut out for us
fortunately he came to the right place
were not just a band-aid kind of team
we're a group of computer scientists
mathematicians engineers and a cancer
researcher who understood that in order
to cure the sickness of a system as big
as governments we needed to examine the
whole body and then we needed to drill
down all the way from their organs into
the tissues all the way to single cells
so that we could properly make a
diagnosis so with our marching orders
from the President himself we embarked
on the purest of the scientific method
collecting data on all the data we could
get our hands on making hypotheses
creating solutions one after the other
so we met with hundreds of individuals
who work at government agencies from the
tax agency the land office utilities
company the agency that's responsible
for registering companies and with each
of them we observe them as they served
customers we documented their processes
because most of them are manyö we also
just went back and look at a lot of
their previous paperwork to trial really
understand to try and diagnose what
bodily malfunctions had occurred they
left it at 136 spot on the World Bank
list what did we find
well in Kenya it was taking 72 days for
business owner to register their
property compared to just one day in New
Zealand which was one second under well
bumpiest it took 158 days to get a new
electric connection in Korea it took 18
days if you wanted to get a construction
permit so you could put up a building in
Kenya it was going to take you a hundred
and twenty five days in Singapore which
is ranked first that would only take you
26 days now god forbid you had to go to
court to get help in being able to
settle a dispute to enforce a contract
because that process alone would take
you 403
55 days and if that wasn't bad enough
you would lose 40% of the of your claim
in just feeds legal fees and forcement
fees court fees now I know what you're
thinking for that to exist such
inefficiencies in a la seconde country
must be corruption the very cells that
run the show must be corrupt to the bone
I thought so too actually when we
started out I was I thought I was gonna
find so much corruption I was literally
either gonna die or get killed in the
process
but when we dug deeper we didn't find
corruption in the classic sense slimy
gangsters lurking in the darkness
waiting to grease the palms of their
friends what we found was an
overwhelming sense of helplessness our
government was cyclical government
employees felt helpless they felt that
they were not empowered to drive change
and when people feel stuck and then and
helpless they stopped seeing their role
in a bigger system disgusted to think
that the work they do doesn't matter in
driving change and when that happens
things slow down fall through the cracks
and inefficiencies flourish now imagine
with me if you had a process that you
had to you had to go through had no
other alternatives
this process was inefficient complex and
very very slow what would you do I think
you might start by trying to find
somebody to outsource with to so that
they can just take care of that for you
if that doesn't work maybe you would
consider paying somebody futures
unofficially take care of it on your
behalf especially if you thought nobody
was going to cut you not out of my list
or grid just dynamic so that you get
something to work for you so that you
can move on unfortunately that is the
beginning of corruption and it's left to
try
vengo it fits into the whole system and
before you know it the whole body is
sick no English
we had to start by making sure that
every single stakeholder we worked with
hide a shared vision for what we wanted
to do so we met with everyone from the
clock who sold obviously remove staples
from application package to the legal
drafters of attorney general's office to
the clerks who are responsible for
serving business owners when they came
to access government services and we
then we made sure that they understood
how their day-to-day actions were
impacting our ability as a country to
create new jobs and to attract
investments
no one's role is too small everyone's
role those vital now guess what we
started to see a coalition of government
employees who are excited and ready to
drive into began to grow and form and
together we started to implement changes
that impacted the service delivery of
our country today results in just two
years
Kenya's ranking moved from 136 to 92
and in recognition of the significant
reforms we've been able to implement in
such a short time Kenya was recognized
to be among the top three global
reformers in the world two years in a
row are we fully healthy now we have
some serious work still to do I like to
think about these three years like a
weight loss program it's that time after
a month of hard grueling work at the gym
and then you get your first time to
weigh yourself and you've lost 20 pounds
you're feeling unstoppable now some of
you may think this doesn't apply to you
you're not from Kenya you don't intend
to be an entrepreneur but think with me
for just a moment when is the last time
you access the government service
maybe applied for your driver's license
tried to do your taxes on your own it's
usually in this political and global
economy to want to give up when you
think about transforming government we
can easily resign to the fact or to the
thinking that government is too
inefficient to correct and fixable
you might even rarely get some key
government responsibilities to other
sectors to bundle solutions or to just
give up at you're helpless but just
because the system is sick doesn't mean
it's dime we cannot afford to give up
when it comes to the challenges of
fixing our government in the end what
really makes our government healthy is
when healthy self that's you and I get
to the ground roll up our sleeves refuse
to be helpless and believe that
sometimes all it takes is for us to
create some space for healthy self to
grow and thrive thank you
[Applause]